and quarterbacks will be the dominant
theme for free agency which begins on
march 18.
our list was published yesterday of the
top 100 free agents now i can take no
credit or blame for it no but very well
played serene williams puts it together
if it's great she gets the credit if
it's bad i got nothing to do with it
right it's great and and i trust her she
does it for us every year it is not easy
to do because you're taking all of the
different shapes and sizes and positions
and cramming them into one bucket but
quarterback continues to be the dominant
position for the national football
league and look at the quarterbacks on
this list one two three six seven and
eight in the top ten half of the top ten
are all quarterbacks and number one dak
prescott and you know we've talked about
this earlier what would dak prescott be
worth if he was on the market unfettered
like number two drew brees like number
three tom brady would he get 40 million
dollars a year if he was free and clear
for any team to pursue i don't think he
would get that i think he'd get close to
it i do think he'd become the highest
paid player in the history of the sport
you know and again you know usually the
quarterback who's a franchise guy and up
next is the guy that becomes that and
yeah i think he would be in that
conversation i think he'd probably pass
up russell wilson and uh you know
somewhere between 36 37 million dollars
a year something like that with a huge
guarantee salary but he certainly
deserves to be the number one player on
your list here i that that i do agree
with so you agree with that i do agree
with that beyond that how do you i have
a feeling you're going to disagree with
number two and number three well i mean
i i'm not putting
drew brees or tom brady over ryan
tannehill at this part of their career
no i'm not you know first off i have an
issue with drew brees being two and
teddy bridgewater being 20. you know i'm
one that'll sit here and i don't i know
this is gonna sound like i'm a hater i
think the saints would have gone 13-3
with teddy bridgewater too i mean they
went five and a half
i know they went 5-0 with them you know
they went 8-3 with drew brees so i you
know again i know drew brees is awesome
but yeah i think that's a little
aggressive
brady and brees at this point how much
you know we hear all the time that when
a new quarterback plays it takes four to
six weeks to figure out exactly what
he's doing how much did bridgewater
benefit from only playing five games
like if he had played five more would
defenses have begun to figure him out
yeah no i think maybe to a degree but i
think this again this is why i probably
don't give saints quarterbacks enough
credit in general to begin with because
of the guy being the play caller you
know hey we know drew brees is going to
throw the ball short and over the middle
but yet it works every freaking week the
whole season it's because sean payton so
that's where he's special to getting
he's a system well no but i'm just
saying he has a quarter he has a a pike
caller who's special at not uh giving
tells on some of his go-to plays or
formations or being creative to get the
same thing but a different way and
that's where he's special now a lot of
great quarterbacks i've had great
systems around them my concern about
tannehill continues to be the reality
that yes he had injuries in the past
yeah and i feel like last year may have
had a certain element of lightning in a
bottle where planets lined up just right
sure he threw caution to the wind he had
stared the end of his career right in
the face so you know we saw how many how
many times did he dive into the end zone
right for a touchdown not not the chris
sims don't hurt me dive that you did you
know your little pivot to the outside
just diving right into the linebacker
how dare you i know i do i dare but but
i mean he was
fearless yeah because what the hell he's
got nothing to lose right and now he
gets paid all of a sudden he's got
something to lose yeah now he's the
number one guy he's the face of a
franchise now he's got something to lose
now the pressure's higher and you know
the things that happen in miami do they
start happening again that's my concern
especially from an injury standpoint can
you trust him to stay healthy once you
pay him 30 million a year or something
close to it that would be my trepidation
yeah no yeah i i hear you and you know i
don't know if he'll be able to command a
30 million a year price tag i would
think it would probably be a little less
than that but
that is the number one concern i
understand that you know my big thing is
this yeah he got hurt in miami okay i
get it and sometimes injuries happen you
know but you get hurt when you play on
crappy teams and man he was on a lot of
teams that had crappy offensive lines i
mean crappy that's all we talked about
when he was there in miami was how
crappy their offensive line was i mean
so that is going to lead to injuries
when you play against that especially if
you're then athletic and talented and
you try to make plays happen that way
and it doesn't always mean just because
you got injured early in your career hey
look at drew brees he got hurt never got
hurt again we were all going man i don't
he might be injury prone is this guy
ever going to be the same so you know i
understand the questions there i get it
but i think the way tana hill played
throughout his career when he was
healthy in miami as we've talked about a
lot it's a little better than it gets
credit for and then what we saw last
year was not just good it was really
good i mean it was a special year it was
a special year for him and that's where
i just go i can't put drew brees and tom
brady over ryan tannehill at this point
of their career because the things i saw
the last seven or eight weeks of the
season tanner hill
outplayed them there's it's not even a
discussion it's it's he made a lot of
big plays we saw some moments so late in
the year where it was almost like the
jimmy garoppolo approach with ryan
tannehill where they they weren't using
it much now you don't need to when
you've got jim brown right at running
back but i look i
well there was use like he didn't throw
the ball a lot in the ravens game but
they were useful throws he threw the
ball early on efficient right efficient
they threw they were aggressive he threw
a deep post for a touchdown he threw a
fade to the left back corner right but
then they got a lead and they just said
screw it let's just keep running this
big horse derrick henry and that took
away from it so it wasn't like they
tried to hide him he kind of struck
early and then they just said we're
going to play the formula we think that
best gives us a chance to win the game
to me that's different than the jimmy
garoppolo way we're going to talk to
mike frable the titans coach later in
the day but we can pose the question to
him directly why is there this
trepidation why is this hesitation why
is this guy not signed like get him
signed like right well because there and
we can't talk to him directly about tom
brady but there is this sense out there
that the titans may be thinking about
making a run of tom brady and you seem
to be a firm believer they're far better
off sticking with tannehill than they
would be doing a short-term thing with
tom brady well i do i mean i think
what two things one yes i think tana
hill's better than brady at this point
two
i think you danger yourself a little bit
too if tom brady decides he just wants
to play one more one year all of a
sudden you're back in like damn we let
ryan tannehill go and now we don't have
crap at quarterback marcus mariota's not
here isn't that part of the courtship
though don't you say to him at some
point look if we're gonna come after you
if we're gonna sign you we need to know
you're gonna be here for two years okay
make a commitment to us man-to-man
face-to-face eyeball to eyeball that
you're going to be here at least yeah
well i think that has to have has to
happen now the other part of that is hey
you're 43 and then okay you said two
years but what happens if you're 43 and
you're tearing acl at the end of the
year because you're getting old and all
things like that or father time wins
that's right he's going to win it's
winning right now we saw it i know tom
brady's the goat he's the man what did
you see that made you think father tom
is winning now you you know what i saw i
saw you tell me what you said seeing
this in the pocket you know unwilling to
stand in there and take a shot to maybe
get the aggressive completion being
careful with jump balls down the
sideline and throwing them five yards
out of bounds you know why i don't know
whether he's protecting his quarterback
numbers there or doesn't i don't know
what it is but the play was good but not
special i didn't sit there for the first
time ever this is the first time ever
all right
we went through a whole season i can't
look at one game and say the patriots
won that game because of tom brady not
one there's not one game i go ooh they
won it because of tom brady they won
every game because of their defense and
they just played kind of efficient
offense where they didn't screw it up
and i think that tells you a lot too and
i don't mean to say that i hate talking
but doesn't doesn't that tell you that
there i mean because the big question is
what are the patriots going to do yeah
are they going to keep tom brady and i i
can tell you that within the
organization yeah
there is a very real
belief that he may leave yeah i i get it
look i think people in the media have
accepted that right i'm just not so sure
that folks
who aren't in the media patriots fans
foxborough yeah new england fans i think
there is a strong belief in the
organization that he very well may leave
yeah the question becomes what does bill
belichick want and think about it from a
football standpoint right
football versus business from a football
standpoint what bill belichick would put
as a value on tom brady versus what a
team like the chargers would put or the
raiders will put could you imagine tom
brady as a member of the las vegas
raiders your buddy john gruden yeah
finally realizing his dream of going
rock climbing with tony who is so cool
you should see how he talks to
waitresses he gets free pie right he's
so cool he gets tom brady they sell out
that stadium every week las vegas
becomes the destination every time that
team plays there right they will sell
more black and silver brady 12 jerseys
assuming the stabler family signs off on
it even though the raiders don't they
don't retire numbers there's going to be
brady number 12 yeah and they will sell
like no jersey has ever sold in history
the nfl and that's a business decision
not a football decision right they're
greater words for them that are the
people traders the chargers can make a
business decision
bill belichick is going to make a
football decision and that in and of
itself is going to manifest itself in
dramatically different offers right to
the point where brady's gonna look at it
and say you don't value me no that's not
the issue yeah these other teams value
you as a commodity right not as a
football right we're we're valuing you
as a football player and we can't tie up
30 million 35 million whatever it is
yeah where the br where teams like the
chargers and the raiders can't yeah no i
think that is spot on you're right
there's way more financial value as far
as to the chargers of the raiders with
tom brady as compared to the new england
patriots it's not even close
and you know i do think that bill would
be fine but you know happy to have tom
back but like you said i mean like we
just talked about with chase young as
far as the you know not working out it's
a business and bill's not going to
sacrifice what he thinks is the the
welfare of his team for the next four to
five years just to sign brady up to some
huge lucrative deal for one more year or
two more years or whatever it may be you
know bill this is where bill's amazing
he does not let emotions come into play
he plays it by business and brains he
does not let his heart and emotions get
involved and i think he's already
telling you you know i think they're
giving us this the clues the signals
without saying it hey we'll have them
back but we're not going to overpay them
we're not going to pay them 30 or 35
million a year they don't think he's
worth that at this point and nor do i
think they think that fits you know what
they're trying to build as a team either
there's a report that the patriots will
be meeting with agent don yee who
represents tom brady here in
indianapolis look he's going to meet
with everybody now the meetings with
everyone except the patriots are
tampering but it's going to happen it
happens all the time every team does it
but coming out of the scouting combine
tom brady will know what's behind door
number two right whatever that is
whether it's chargers raiders titans
dolphins whoever he'll find out after
that what's really behind door number
one and they'll make a decision and it
very well could be and i know the
organization portions of the
organization bracing for tom brady
choosing to leave and if it happens look
we'll be talking about it a lot but
folks if it happens you can't be mad at
the patriots you can't be mad at
ownership you can't be mad at the
organization they got 20 years out of
the 199th overall pick in the 2001 draft
and six super bowl wins for crying out
that's right how can you be mad about it
if a grown man in his 40s who isn't
going to be with you much longer anyway
yes right chooses to finish his career
somewhere else that's right it's just
part of the business especially this day
and age in the nfl there's there's
nothing wrong it's been a great run i
don't want to see brady go anywhere else
i'll be one to tell you that right now i
want to see him in new england i do you
know i think they're i just want to see
him you know be in that uniform first of
all he is like the number one symbol of
a new england patriot for me
uh it you know i'm tradition
traditionalist that way and of course i
feel like i want to see them make one
more run out of two because we know
their team is good they're a few players
away they need a few more weapons on
offense certainly we know maybe another
defensive lineman or two and they're
going to be right back in the afc
championship conversation
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports